-Hi. Nice to meet you. Yeah.
No, here we go. Let's just see
and see where we end up.
-Let's just see.
It might be a tie.
Oh, I didn't do --
I did that wrong, didn't I
-It doesn't matter.
Wait. Is that a tie?
-That's a tie, baby.
-No.
-Yes.
-It's a tie.
Okay, what does that mean?
[ Laughter ]
What?
-Dealer loses!
-Ryan...
-I'm glad it's not
called "Balljack."
I'm just gonna put that
out there right now.
Oh!
Wow!
♪♪♪♪
-We're gonna play a game her
called "Slapjack."
It works the same as blackjack
but at the end of each round
the winner gets to slap
the loser across the face
with a giant prosthetic hand
[ Laughter, applause ]
First to win three rounds
is the winner.
-Nice.
-We take turns dealing.
No splits.
If it's a tie, the dealer loses.
Ryan, as our guest,
you deal first.
-Good stuff. Burn card?
-Yeah. Good stuff. Good luck
-Yeah. Burn card, of course.
Later.
-Worst flow ever. Okay.
-Yeah. No, that was good.
No, I liked that.
That was good. Okay.
Okay. 7 -- I like that.
-Alright.
-Yours down, yeah.
-Ooh-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo.
-This is fantastic.
-This is looking good for you.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Oh!
-No, I'm feeling good
about this one.
Yeah.
-You want a hit, yeah?
-Hit me!
-Unh!
-[ Laughing ]
-Sucks.
-I'm gonna stay.
Yeah, I'm very happy.
Hi. Nice to meet you. Yeah
No, here we go. Let's just see
and see where we end up.
-Let's just see.
It might be a tie.
Oh, I didn't do --
I did that wrong, didn't I
-It doesn't matter.
Wait. Is that a tie?
-That's a tie, baby.
-No.
-Yes.
-It's a tie.
Okay, what does that mean?
[ Laughter ]
What?
-Dealer loses!
-Ryan...
-I'm glad it's not
called "Balljack."
I'm just gonna put that
out there right now.
Oh!
Wow!
-You fought back.
-Where does --
Blazing speed!
-[ Laughs ]
You almost -- You almost
fought back with your head
-Where does rage like that
come from, Jimmy?
-It's not rage!
It's a giant rubber hand!
-That was amazing!
-No, it's not.
-I lost consciousness.
-Oh, you did not.
Oh, my gosh.
-Weirdly, it was your life
that flashed before my eyes.
-Do I burn one?
Yeah, burn one.
-Burn one. Here we go.
Now this one's turns up, right
-Yes, sir.
-This to you.
-Oh, I like that.
That's good for me.
-And then down to me.
-Yeah. Yeah.
You keep it down. Yeah.
-And then down to you?
-No, no.
-Up to you.
-Whoa. [ Chuckles ]
Ohh! Jimmy!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Do you want --
[ Laughs ]
Do you want to hit?
Are you hoping for a 1?
-Jimmy, I'm going to stay.
-You learned a lot
on this movie, apparently.
-I did. Yes.
-All right.
So, I flip this guy over,
and that's that,
so I'm gonna have to hit.
-Yeah, you're gonna wanna...
-So I'm going to do this.
Thank you so much for...
Just go for it, buddy.
Just go for it.
[ Slap! ]
-Ohh!
♪♪♪♪
-Really...
[ Laughter ]
I mean, wow, right?
[ Applause ]
[ Slap echoes ]
That was ugly.
-[ Chuckles ] Mama?
-Wow.
-Mama, I'm comin' for you!
-Grand-papa?
-[ Laughs ]
-Do we have NFL
concussion protocol?
-We have -- No. Gosh. That was
a good smack right there.
-That was very good.
Lot of skin contact there.
-Okay. Good. Yeah.
My toupee almost came off.
-I go -- I go. Me first, right
-Yeah.
-Yeah. No. Is that right?
No, it goes to me first.
-Oh, it goes to you first.
Take that one off. Yeah.
Up. You're right.
This one goes down.
-That goes down to you.
-Poker was my...
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
-Oh, God. This one is...
-No, it's to me again.
-You want it, though?
-[ Laughs ]
Yes. I definitely...
"Do you want it, though?" Yeah
-Damn it!
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
You are the best dealer ever
-Yeah, I know.
-"You sure you don't
want that 19?"
-I need to go reshoot some
scenes from "Mississippi Grind."
-No. I'm going to stay at this
-Yeah, I think you should.
Uh, I'm gonna hit.
-Yeah. No. Wait.
You flip over first.
-You're right. You're right.
-Ooh. Okay. You got 6.
That's fantastic.
6 is good. Oh, wait.
This is interesting.
-This just got really good
didn't it?
-Now, if you get
a face card or a 10...
-Yeah, you're gonna get hurt
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah. So I get to --
I get to hit right now.
-Yeah.
-Ohh!
-Ohh! Damn it!
-Great having you on the show.
-It's been very nice to be here.
-Congrats on the movie.
-Don't -- Go hard. Go hard
-[ Breathing sharply ]
[ Slap! ]
-Ryan! He's okay! He's okay!
-I'm okay!
-He's okay!
-We're okay!
-He's okay, you guys.
He's all right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was vicious.
-That was not vicious.
You guys,
our thanks to Ryan Reynolds.
Jason and I are about
to play a game called Slapjack
Now, it works the same
as blackjack,
but at the end of each round
the winner gets
to slap the loser across
the face
with a giant prosthetic hand
[ Cheers and applause ]
First to win -- First to win
three rounds --
It's not gonna hurt that much.
-I'm finding if there's
any horseshoes in here.
[ Both laugh ]
-Maybe there is.
-Maybe there is in this one.
[ Both laugh ]
-Alright, here's the deal.
I'm so scared right now.
We're gonna keep score
on screen.
We take turns dealing,
no splits.
If it's a tie, dealer loses.
Jason, as our guest,
you're gonna deal first.
Two cards each,
loser gets slapped.
You can burn the first one
if you want,
if you don't trust me.
-I don't trust you,
but I don't need to do that.
Ooh.
-Alright, don't flip
that over.
That one's yours.
-It's yours.
-Is that right?
-First one to you.
-Yeah, yeah. Cool.
-You should learn
how to play this.
You'll do a lot better.
-Really?
Ooh!
That's awful, isn't it?
-13.
Well...?
It's all yours.
I got a 10.
You better be sweating.
-Hit me.
Don't hit me, but hit me.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh!
Tough decision, old pal.
-Not really.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Imitates squeaking ]
-I'm gonna stay, man.
-You're gonna stay?
-That's right. 17.
-Well, let's have
a little look, shall we?
Let's have a little look.
Ooh.
Oh, oh, no!
Should've burnt the first card
-[ Laughs ]
-Ohh!
-Oh, it's a tie!
-It's a tie!
-That means...
[ Laughs ]
-Are you sure that's right
-We said -- Yeah, yeah.
I swear, that was written
on the --
-Go on, then.
-I didn't write it.
A writer wrote it.
-[ Laughs ]
-He's sitting over there.
Alright, ready?
-Go ahead.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready?
-Yeah, go on, then.
-That's not true!
That's not true!
That's not --
I didn't hit you that hard
That's your -- I did not
hit him that hard!
I did not hit you that hard!
This is a foam hand.
That's not real.
That's not real at all.
This is a fake hand.
That was a fall.
-Call the chiropractor.
-[ Laughs ]
Don't get me back for that
That was a soft hit.
-That was aw--
-Oh, my God!
-Can you believe that?
-No, I don't believe that!
-[ British accent ]
Alright, here we go.
First card goes to you.
[ Laughter ]
-Second card...
-It's face-up.
-Yeah, well, you turn it
'cause I'm tired.
-You turn it over.
Turn my card over.
I'm gonna do it only
because I always wanted --
I wanted to hear you say that.
Bang!
[ Both laugh ]
And no wild cards, either.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Normal voice ]
Leave this one down?
-Down, down.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one up here.
-[ Chuckles ]
-This is just gonna
be a bummer
if you don't get to slap m
at all.
-Yeah, I feel this one's good.
Just warm up this little hand.
-[ Laughs ]
Ooh.
-[ Clears throat ]
Right. Hit me.
-How much, normally,
is a queen worth?
[ Laughter ]
-You better hope
that's a queen.
You really want that
to be a queen. Come on.
-12. So, if you get a 10,
oopsy-daisy!
-Give me a -- a little 9
will do me nicely.
I should get this hand ready
-Here we go.
Mm-hmm-hmm-hmm?
-Lucky 9s?
-Yeah...
-Ohh!
-Dude!
-No!
-It's tot-- I'll be
nice with you.
-Go ahead. Go on.
-It's so great having you
on the show.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is my first win!
I finally beat Jason Statham
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Next time!
-Give me a good slap.
You can give me a good hit
Give me a good one.
-[ Grunts ]
-Do we have that in --
Do we have that in slow-mo
that last one?
-[ Laughs ]
-You put a little bit
too much.
Our thanks to Jason Statham,
everybody!